Ok, xin chào các bạn. Hôm nay
ờ
không biết các bạn nhìn rõ xem.
Ui, cái này có sợ dính thì sao không? Sợ
dính mặt người ta
lại bl.
Đây để tôi để cỡ rất nhỏ ta không nhìn
thấy mặt người ta đâu.
Bơ chỉ có bl hẳng thôi. Đ xem
nhưng mà FL nói cho anh t xấu xấu ấy.
Đây thế này được chưa?
đỡ hơn rồi. Ồ ok.
Xin chào các bạn. Những thứ nào cũng
chẳng biết có ai xem thôi.
Ok thì hôm nay mình đang ngồi có ai nghe
rõ em có khi nhờ em vào xem nghe rõ
rõ mà đúng không?
Mình để link h cho mọi người nhé.
Thì hôm nay như bảo là mình sẽ
cố livestream thường xuyên để mà
ch
ôn các thứ thế
cái phương này tốt ạ. Đây em thấy không?
kiểu nó tiếng nó hiển thị tiếng Anh ấ
xong rồi kiểu chỉ vào hiển thị tiếng
thì hôm qua
như tôi đã nói là tôi sẽ cố livestream
đều đúng không ạ? Để để link cho anh em
tham khảo nhá.
Và tôi sẽ ôn luyện
luyện cái a
cái này nhở.
Ồ
hai ngày liên tiếp chia
cố gắng chứ phải cố gắng chứ. Long
Nguyễn Phương Hoàng
đúng không? Tôi chả biết là đặt tên ông
có đúng hay không. [khịt mũi]
Nếu mà mấy ông để kỹ để ý là hôm nay tôi
mới cài thêm một vài nữa. Đó. Hôm nay
tôi sẽ dùng thử Davin bằng đố mấy ông
biết trừ em Thiên không biết em Thiên có
vào đây không là đố nếu ông biết là
workspace chịu nhờ không nhớ tên lắm
Long Nguyệt
ha.
Anh nghe này xịn không? Appay
à cái này thật ra là ừ nó cà phê
workspace cũng ổn. Ở đây khá là ổ ở
chuẩn bị hưng ở Hà Nội nhá. Ừ.
Tai nghe này xịn không ấy. Tai nghe này
là
nó là free clip tức là nó là kiểu open
ear. Tức là nó đầu tiên thì mấy ông tự
mấy ông đánh giá được cái mic gâ mọi thứ
như nào nhá.
Và nó là open ear, tức là nó là kiểu nó
giống kiểu phên tai kiểu như này này.
Tức là nó không
có lọc tạp âm, nó không có kiểu
gọi nhó
không xịn lắm theo kiểu nó chỉ được cái
tiện là việc là khi mà ông ngồi trong
môi trường mở tránh bị đau tai, những
cái bịt kính lỗ tai hay là tránh bị kiểu
ngồi lâu ông bị khó chịu khi mà kiểu
nghe thống ồn nó làm game khó chịu ấy
thì ra cái tai nghe của open kia nó sắc
cái gì đấy nhưng mà tôi không rõ về cái
chất lượng của mic nhá.
Ờ không ch là xung quanh đây nếu mà mọi
người có nghe tiếng xung quanh thì th
mọi người cũng có nói chuyện bình thường
và tôi đang nói với cái âm lượng cũng
không hề to đâu. Không biết mấy ông có
nghe tôi nói to không tôi đang nói
chuyện không hết thì tí tôi có thể thử
tai nghe khác cho tôi. Tự và Sony chồng
ngôn ở đây con Sony X5 nhưng mà không
biết được là mic con này so với con đấy
nếu như thế nào nhưng mà đúng nghĩa là
nếu mà đeo con chấm ngồn kia đúng nghĩa
tôi không nghe được xung quanh môi
trường nào tôi sợ tôi khi mình nói là
nói ch hóa đúng không đấy
còn con mic này thì con này con của
Huawei con này cũng hơn bao phủ đấy nên
là tôi đá sẽ
kiểu khá là ổn Nó không phải là con nghe
tai nghe
nếu mà tính là tai nghe kiểu kiểu dạng
như là ừ to highlight đúng không? Tay
nghe trên bluetooth thì nó là không phải
nghe tầm tầm thấp không phải tầm giá rẻ
tầm trung đổ lên á
cáo cho nên là có người hỏi tôi trả lời
sao lại bây giờ dọ tù quảng cáo.
Ok thì hôm nay chúng ta bắt đầu buổi hai
đúng không ạ? Hôm qua em làm thử một cái
tạo ra một cái đề buổi thứ hai rồi. Ừ
thì hôm qua tôi cũng có sửa lại một tí
cái comment không biết là được đấy a lúc
mà ngồi làm mấy ông thì có hình như lúc
đấy chưa chốt hoàn toàn. Tôi vừ sao tôi
có cái gọi là skill này để xử lý. Tức là
mấy ông có thể đầu tiên mấy ông kéo cái
code của cái này về nhá.
Nếu ông có những cái bộ đề đúng không?
Nó sẽ kiểu dạng là đây tôi có kiểu
question là một cái kiểu câu hỏi đúng
không? Đấy
các thứ giờ thế này đấy thì tôi có một
bộ đề ở đây rồi tôi sẽ dùng cái những
cái skill command nào đó để
kiếp.
Đầu tiên thì mình giống như hôm qua tôi
làm và tôi sẽ trả lời. Tôi tặng một cái
file để tôi trả lời đúng không? Xong rồi
tôi dùng cái lệnh một cái lệnh nào đó để
tôi chấm điểm của câu trả lời của tôi.
Nhưng ngoài ra thì vẫn sẽ có một cái gọi
là tôi sẽ tạo cái file trả lời của tôi
tên là My Solution là giải pháp của tôi
đúng không ạ? Đấy, còn có một cái nữa là
official solution tức là
kiểu chính thức câu trả lời chẩn nó nên
là như nào. Đương nhiên là tôi dùng AI
để làm hết. Có thể đúng, có thể là không
trọn vẹn lắm thì mấy ông cũng có thể giả
sửa cái thứ gì đó. Nhưng mà ý tôi là tôi
tạo cái bộ đề này mục tiêu không phải
mỗi tôi làm mà dướ sau mấy ông cũng có
thể tham khảo mấy ông kéo về mấy ông tự
làm. Rồi mấy ông sẽ tự chạy những câu
lệnh. Nó sẽ có hai câu lệnh ở đây. Một
câu lệnh là chấm bị là một câu lệnh thứ
hai tôi thử nghĩ khá là hay đó câu lệnh
tạo không phải tạo bộ đề nữa mà tạo câu
hỏi trắc nghiệm dựa trên những cái những
cái gì?
Dự trên chính bộ đề này và dựa trên
chính câu hỏi và đáp án các thứ vân vân.
Tức là sao? Nghĩa là nghĩa là hôm qua
tôi có một cái khái nhượng là keyword từ
khóa là mấy ông nếu ông làm cái bộ đề
đấy ví dụ bộ đề này mình phải liên quan
đến kiểu à tránh xung đột lịch này đấy
các thứ này cái này là liên quan đến là
conflict detection này đấy xong rồi còn
concr
này chẳng hạn đấy là những từ khóa Thì
thì
cái phần command mà phía sau mấy ông
dùng có thể dùng bất kỳ lúc nào nhá. Có
thể dùng theo bộ đề, theo ngày, theo một
cái gì đó để tạo ra một bộ flash c tức
là mấy cái mấy cái gọi là một cái tôi
chưa dịch được cái từ đấy từ ra tiếng
Việt đã khá là kiểu giống các thẻ bài
tôi ngắn gọn là cái cái từ khóa này định
nghĩa nó là gì. Đấy kiểu thế để mà mình
dễ học ghi nhớ cái từ khóa đấy này. Đấy
nó cả bộ trắc nghiệm nữa để mà về sau
mấy ông có thể hiểu
trong đống bài như hôm qua tôi có nói đó
là mấy ông sẽ bị một cái là trả lời xong
hết Việt Nam thậm chí là xem đáp án rồi
vân vân vân vân rồi đúng không ạ? vẫn sẽ
quên đi nên thành ra là đấy.
Anh ơi cho em hỏi anh đi phỏng vấn được
người phỏng vấn hỏi. Em muốn lock
request body
thì em đưa solu là chấn nào? Lock
request body à. À cái này thì hồi trước
mình đã từng làm thực tế đấy bởi vì nó
là kiểu rất là dài
bảo là một cái đoạn request này kiểu
thường mình sẽ lưu lại để mà mình đi bất
hoặc là c để mà trết lại
dữ liệu hay tr các thứ thứ thường mình
sẽ không dùng trong
SQL trong trường hợp này thường NSQL
thường là một là NSQ
Kiểu mình chia chia ki ra nói chung là
cũng có thể là nó mongo thật ra mongo là
tôi không tôi từng dùng biết qua mongo
thôi nhưng mà tôi thấy không ít ai trình
mongo để lưu
lưu tại lock request lắm mà sẽ thường là
lưu trong etic search để mà tra tìm kiếm
nó một cách nào hoặc là ờ của bên tôi
đang dùng là có kết hợp relock chẳng hạn
G lock nhưng mà lock thì nó hướng về tí
tí đi bx hơn là kiểu để lưu request lock
cá nhân tôi thì tôi sẽ dùng mấy cái kiểu
một là electric search hai là min search
đấy new search đúng không nhở
hình như tôi nhớ tên chính xác nó new
search đấy thì cái đấy để nghĩa là dạng
no để mình lưu lại đó đấy
à và đương nhiên mình sẽ ngoài lưu lưu
lại cái
dùng
cái nào để bắ request và relock ở đâu
vậy anh và loock
ờ thì em nó đẩy lên backend của em mà
thì em anh thường là xử lý cái đấy nó sẽ
là anh sẽ xử lý ví dụ là ở dự án của
công ty anh hiện tại thì sẽ xử lý nó ở
dạng anh anh đang dùng ngôn ngữ là PP
Lavel nhá thì sẽ xử lý nó ngay ở cái
tầng tầng là tầng aware tất cả khi vừa
nhận thì quên mình sẽ lắp lại luôn nhưng
cái việc đấy cái việc lưu lại bởi vì lưu
lại trong no thì xử lý nó rất là nhanh
và nó hạn chế là việc kiểu ảnh hưởng đến
cái luồng khác thì mình có thể đẩy vào
job hay đẩy vào đâu đấy để mà xử lý
nhanh thực ra là insert vào nhanh á sả
không ảnh hưởng gì cái tốc độ phần dưới
là ý anh là tránh việc nếu nó mà lưu lỗi
thì nó cũng không nên ảnh hưởng đến cái
luồng xử lý bình thường thường của mình
đúng không? Bởi vì nó tính là nó chỉ là
một tính năng tự thêm thôi. Đó
đúng rồi. Có thể lock đẩy lên một cái
nền tảng nào đó như bạn kia bảo tôi cũng
chưa biết cl nào nhưng đại khái nó đẩy
lên một cái gì đó we để mà lưu lại.
Nghĩa là nó là chưa đến cái phần xử lý
logic, chưa đến phần để xử lý một cái gì
cả mà ngay từ lúc mà mình nhận được thì
mình lập tức mình lưu lại đã. Đấy.
Ừ. Đương nhiên mình nên lưu thêm cả
những thông tin của
người dùng nữa nếu có thể. Nhưng mà
thường là nếu thế nó lại vào cái tầng
khác mất rồi. Nghĩa là ví dụ là hồi
trước là tôi lưu là còn lưu lại cả ID
của người đã làm thế thì rõ ràng là nó
phải vào cái tầng logic phải tầng truy
vấn DB rồi mọi thứ đúng không? Đấy nhưng
mà khi mà đến cái tầng đấy nó bắt đầu
lên lẽ
sẽ chỉ để đi bốc thôi là nó sẽ không nếu
mà giả sử tự nhiên chưa đến tầng đấy mà
nó lỗi thì khó đúng không? Đấy nên là
thường là mình lưu nhá mình lưu request
có thể là mình sẽ lưu ở ngay tầng mid
được nhưng mà lúc đấy nó sẽ có hơi bị
khái niệm như mình vừa nói là raw tức là
dữ liệu thu mình chưa có sàn lọc dữ liệu
mình chưa biết được là nó thuộc về cái
người nào th nên là mình nghĩ ừ đấy là
một câu hỏi rất là hay mình ghi phản ở
trong đề này cũng được đấy để mà mình
tính về cả bài toán việc là v xong mình
tra cứu một cái người nào đó ví dụ
Thường là mình sẽ chỉ biết lưu thế lưu
lại theo dạng IP để mình chọn người dùng
theo giải IP giải này mình chọn nó đúng
không?
Nhưng mà ý là mình cũng vì xong mà mình
xác định được là cụ thể một cái ông
người dùng, một ông user nào đó có những
cái thao tác nào và ông ấy giặt lỗi ở
đoạn nào bởi vì nó sẽ còn liên quan đến
bài toán là
kiểu dạng là khi mà người dùng mà gặp
lỗi đôi khi người ta thông báo lại với
mình người ta bỏ luôn
người ta bỏ luôn sản phẩm của mình chẳng
hạn đúng không? thì mình sẽ còn lịch sử
xem lại để biết được là người dùng này
đã tha tác mọi thứ như thế nào thì mình
nghĩ là mình lưu cái đấy theo người dùng
được thì càng tốt
thì cái đấy nó sẽ phải cá nhân hóa hơn
đúng không nó sẽ phải chỉnh hơn nữa
được thì anh sẽ lôn câu hỏi này vào rất
hay
cảm ơn em
tặng cho em một khô gà
>> [tiếng cười]
>> Ừ. Dùng code
à đây là con Davin này. Tí tôi sẽ dùng
con Davin này xong
à hay dùng luôn nhỉ? Được dùng đi
dùng mới đi. Hôm nay tôi mới hỏi là C
kn
này thì con này vẫn là con cũ của Winf
nên mình sẽ dùng hệ phong mới
hàng mới các thứ xị. Đây tôi muốn tạo
một thư mục mới
trong
đây hai đấy.
với đề bài làm
đó lưu lại request lọc của nội dung
nên như thế nào
để hiện
cứu và debug
ra Nếu thế phải tạo một cái skin nữa ở
đây là skin chuẩn tạo ra đề nhở.
Ui hỏi mới hỏi đã bảo là đối mặt với
main for model rồi không cho dùng luôn
ạ.
Đúng muốn dùng miễn phí hơi khó chả vứt
ở trong này vậy
đây tạo
luôn skill cho tôi.
Đọc cả project
để hiểu
cách làm.
hơi lạm quyền kiểu kiểu có như token ấy
hơi lạ
để extra 2 này xong mới kéo dùng các thứ
các chứ nhỉ không tạm có đi kiểu
vector các thứ
tôi không mượn gì sao sd
đấy SD quid sd được bằng
tạo ra một cái nữa
vô khá nhỏ nên đọc cả project ở đây hợp
lý thử nào
đợi một tí tôi thầ máy cho nóng rồi tôi
sẽ mượn
ở đây xịn thực mà không ạ. Bạn phải
quảng cáo. Đây có cho mượn mượn cái màn
hình màn hình này aota
không biết giảm bao nhiêu ta cũng tầm
1 2 triệu hơn gì đấy với
với cái giá đỡ của laptop rất xịn rất
ngầu.
thầy chuyển chỗ công dụng một con nick
để lọ
cũng được vấn đề cách mà rồi tôi cứ làm
mấy cái kiểu đấy thông cảm tôi bảoên bây
giờ tôi mới học về hệ thống vì mấy ông
thông cảm nhá mỗi tay tôi đang bị hơi
chéo như này trông như kiểu dân chơi
Ro đọc
button đây xem
không đề bài không nên có
gợi ý gì như vấn đề cần nhận ra.
Bạn nên quên mất phải có cái từ khóa bạn
nên hỏi tôi trước khi làm mới đúng
sửa lại cho tôi
ste này là submit inter này là inter
không nhỉ?
mượn cả màn hình luôn. Ừ đúng rồi. là
giá đồ ống thì sẽ là tầm trung tức là
một đồ ống tầm 50 60 nhưng mà ông ngồi
được lâu có đây ngồi cái công thái học
này đó cho ánh sáng mọi thứ xung quanh
không không hề ổn đương nhiên là mọi
người sẽ nói chuyện trao đổi gì gì đó
mọi người không im song sắc đâu không hề
ổn nếu nghe thấy có ổn lắm đậy đúng
không
nói chung là mọi người cũng sẽ làm việc
của mình đấy có những cái gây rất là êm
khác nhá đấy Nhưng nhược điểm nhược điểm
đó là khá là đông á nên mấy ông nên đặt
trước đấy. Ví dụ hôm nay tôi phải đặt m
hình trước
mượn màn hình miễn phí nhá. sẽ mượn các
thứ sẽ miễn phí không không mất gì đâu.
Ừ. Hôm nay anh cũng chuyển chỗ nà anh
ngồi
hôm nay muốn ra ngoài ngoài làm việc
thay đổi không gian tí.
Nhờ nước ở đây cũng ổn.
Thế có khi mà trả lời cũng sẽ phải dùng
ai nữ tất
tạo một cái skin nữa kìa.
Thấy có lười quá nhỉ?
Ơ quên mất rồi. nói cái kiểu này là nói
với
bạn hỏi lại tôi đã có số tiền thứ
muốn
khi dùng B thế này sẽ tự động
rõng
official
solution
khi dùng skill chấm
đánh
trong solution
ở đây sẽ bị một nhược điểm duy nhất
đó là cái tiếng pít píp
mà tôi thấy ở đâu cũng bị thế thôi
từng đến nơi khác nó bị phi pí cái nó
hơi
hội không biết người khác sẽ hơi mất một
sức một tí
có
tự động rằng mẫu chứ
Đấy, nghĩa là bây giờ mình sẽ
là tạo bộ đề cho thầy nhá.
Tôi xin
có cái không hiển thị ở đây. Cái a
phải hiển thị ở đây cái file trên nữa
nhỉ.
Mình bị cái set à
quên tôi trong này tôi ngồi làm đề kia ấ
nhỉ đề này đúng không?
Ok
tôi sẽ tặng luôn cái
hai thằng này là my solution.
Đ
ừ
về bài này là
quyết chế hệ thống xếp lịch và phân công
nhân sự cho nhiều ca là nhiều địa điểm
có rằng bộ về kỹ năng nhịp hành xong đột
lịch
tôi mở cái song song nhá
Ờ nó sắch sẵn xong đi.
Đây
ừ
vì tránh xung đột lịch
nên tôi nghĩ vẫn cần phải có
một database.
Ờ đợi tí tôi chỉnh lại không cho op to
complete ở file này nữa.
Nào ừ
ừ
autoq nè
nè.
Ok.
Database master
để lưu
thông tin
thế hệ thống.
Ừ.
Cái này thực ra là để mà nói là sẽ thiên
về à
cách tạo bản hơn là
cách tạo bản sao cho linh hoạt.
thì
cần liên quan đến ca làm
nhân viên
và kỹ năng
nên sẽ là mối quan hệ
như này nhá là
nhiều nhiều cái trước mắt bảo đó vì một
ngày
luôn luôn cố định
những ta làm
nhất định
nên sẽ
biến
thêm mới
tự động
ca lá được sắp xếp sẵn
Từ đầu tuần
kiểu đăng ký ca làm từ đầu tuần ấy.
Ca nghỉ từ đầu tuần
đương nhiên có hỗ trợ
cho đổi và cho nhau khi có vấn đề.
phát sớm hoặc
có phép nghỉ và cho phép
bỏng nghĩ
thì
à
không một thời gian đã quy ước
ừ có giới thiệu về làm luôn ạ giới hạn
về làm thì bản chất là
giờ với hạn bây giờ là sẽ thống kê
theo từng nhân viên trong một tuần
dựa theo
bản
mỗi nhân viên
sẽ mối quan hệ
nhiều
với các kỹ
để
quản lý có thể
điều chỉnh
link
phối hợp
khi sắch xếp c
à
liên quan đến nhiều địa điểm nữa. Cái
bài toán nó nhiều địa điểm ấ bởi vì à
đôi khi mình sẽ cho nhân viên này sang
tạo bên khác
không đáng kể thế
phải
hỏi lại xem có thể điều phối
nhân viên
cơ sở
Đ anh đang ngồi đâu thế? Thế mà nó dám
dịch là
à đúng rồi anh. Where are you sitting?
Nhưng mà anh đọc nhàn hình. Why are you
sitting? Tại sao mày đang ngồi?
Em đang ngồi ở cà phê mà kiểu working
space.
Anh sẽ ghi cho các bạn là
cá cá
xem có thể điều phối viên cơ sở nào sang
cơ sở khác.
hỗ trợ à
lính họ
được không?
Ví dụ
chỉ qua một vài ngày,
thậm chí có thể lưu lại địa chỉ của nhân
viên địa chỉ của sợ để điều phối
tiện hơn
cũng được.
Hôm nay thầy đổi gió
thế nó để câu tiếng Anh with the picture
changing thing up today.
Ok.
chỉnh thẳng thay đổi môi trường gì cũng
được mà nữa
option
à thử
thử chỉnh lại
đề
đang có sẵn cho tôi đề tôi
viết sẽ số
mã
đã đi kết tôi viết bằng chỉnh sửa đã rồi
mới replace
ở đây cũng có thêm cái nhiệt Đ
vẫn đã xong ra chế và tâm này thôi nên
là
bên a bên pha chế mà làm cái gì á thì nó
sẽ có thể gây ồn phân nào xung quanh đấy
bây giờ cái này an nghĩ tôi nghĩ là tình
trạng cũng tương đối chung vành nơi khó
chạy
trừ khi bây giờ bảo người ta làm về một
cái gì cho chị
Conf
không chỉ sale đâ lạc đúng rồi phải biểu
diễn shift đúng rồi phải biểu diễn biểu
biểu đồ không phải biểu đồ quyển lịch
đấy hiển thị dạng lịch theo tuần
theo tháng để tiện
Cõi s
và với nhân viên thì cũng sẽ cần rõ ràng
để
chỉnh sửa
em sắp ba được vào dự án n với goan toàn
cái mới vạ
Ui chúc mừng em anh không biết cả hai
cái đấy cái đấy cũng chắc chắn mới anh
đâu ngồi làm xong rồi
xem
đâu part
địa điểm số lượng người cần phân công
vào cái phộc chữ năng mỗi nhân sự thực
sáng bật ngày nghỉ và hạ sơ làm việc hệ
thống sân khả Thì cần
ch bà assumment
chính data model phân công cách kiểm tra
xung đột cách xử lý chỉnh sửa đồng lượt
đồng thời và các thiết quan trọng ừ đây
là vẻ hay đấy nhưng mà
assumption này là gì tôi còn chưa biết
cơ đấy.
Ừ
không tâm
ch
với những từ tiếng Anh chuyên ngành
nên
Phú thích
dịch Phật bên dưới.
Ừ.
với đề
fashion
sao lại nhắc tới
chị ai
tam đâu
cô chưa hiểu đoạn này lắm
giải thích
cho tôi ý tưởng của bạn
để
cho
hỏi lại để đưa ra lựa chọn
đăng
thường có khi phải chọn cái mode này
nó toàn tự làm trước không hay lắm.
luồng phân công cách kiểm tra xông đột
cách kiểm tra xông đột thì à
như này trước là tôi từng thiết kế một
lần về cái phân công đi công giáo viên
đi dạy rồi giáo viên thì cũng như là
không phải giáo viên nào cũng dạy được
mọi đúng không ạ đó cũng ngồi thì à
là một cái vụ tương tự của nhưng mà
đương nhiên là nó đơn giản hơn thì
khoảng
nó chia theo lớp thì không có nhiều lớp
lắm
còn có ca các thứ cũng tương tự mà đấy
thật ra hồi đấy cũng chưa có cái vụ là
giới hạn số giờ làm việc đâu. Ông nào
rảnh thư ra hồi đấy còn chả kiểm tra ông
nào rảnh thức ăn đấy thì chắc là cùng
lắm là chỉ có thông báo thôi chứ cũng
không a
nói chung là chưa chặt chẽ lắm vụ đấy
cái này nếu mà chuẩn nhá nó là liên quan
thiết kế thiết kế a gọi là lại nhắc đến
lại cái môn a cấu trúc dữ liệu và giải
thuật bởi vì nó có liên quan đến việc à
các bạn phải vẽ ra mối quan hệ của các
thực thể các thực thể là kiểu à
giáo viên à xong ngồi à
giáo viên kỹ năng x từ đấy tạo ra một
cái gọi là kỹ năng của giáo viên xong
rồi nối đến ca làm rồi nối đến và đương
nhiên ca làm đấy là theo trong ngày giờ
nhất định đấy rồi nối đến a cơ sở ở
trong trường hợp đấy cơ sở đây đấy có
như địa cơ sở đấy ừ chạm chỉ thế đương
nhiên là mình đương nhiên là sau mình
còn tính theo khoản lịch sảnh lịch bận
nghỉ các thứ nữa
nhấy số giờ là nghiệp nữa đúng không
thường là bài toán này nó sẽ nên như nào
nhỉ?
Tôi nghĩ phải có một chút tán riêng nó
mà tôi chưa biết bởi vì bản chất nói là
nó lấp đầy và
mỗi người giả sử là ta bỏ qua là số giờ
làm việc nhá nó là
nó sẽ kiểu giống kiểu rain nếu không
biết từ khóa này không ra pin tức là
xoay xoay xoay tua xoay vòng ấy tức là
thật Sự giả sử là giáo viên tôi cứ nhắc
lại giáo viên nó dễ thện giáo viên dạy
môn a
một môn toán chẳng hạn có hai giáo viên
dạy toán đi đấy thì
có giáo viên a giáo viên bùng dạy toán
nhá lúc đây giáo viên a nhận lớp 1 này
xong rồi đến giáo viên b nhận lớp 2 xong
rồi giáo viên a quay lại nhận lớp 3 rồi
giáo viên
b nhận lớp 4 trắng nhược nó bị khóa tải
hay dồn hết vào giáo viên 1 dột hết vào
giáo viên A xong rồi đến khi nào đầy đầy
lịch của giáo viên A rồi mới chuyện là
giáo viên B thì không được đúng không
đấy mình sẽ soi vòng thế
thì sẽ tránh việc là quá tạ một người
cũng như là để cho
tránh việc xóa cái số giới hạn số giờ
làm việc mà nếu mà giả sử xếp tất cả mọi
người
rồi lấp đầy rồi mà vẫn quá rồi số làm
việc đến lúc mà ông phải tuyển nhân viên
mới
vì ông nhân viên nào cũng qua số làm
việc rồi hết khả năng rồi đấy có nghĩa
là sẽ dùng ro trường hợp này
dùng cơ chế
để kiểm soát
giơ làm tấn Rồi xoay vòng
xả mình bán ph nếu mà
ai cũng bị quá
giờ thì đến lúc
B sách
chuyển thêm nhân viên
format
bỏ hết giữ
Ok. Trong đề bài muốn mức độ gợi ý yêu
cầu đâu?
là gì nhỉ? Cô phải traility cái từ
assumption đợi tí.
Tôi có tạo một cái đó là cái
dịch
Ừ
giải định
Đây thôi cái ngón không mục tiêu đâu.
À quên vừa rồi nó vừa cho chọn song ngữ
xong mình bỏ qua.
Song ngữ cũng hay
như tôi nghĩa là thôi tạm thời trước mắt
là cái
phiên bản này của tôi chắc là để hỗ trợ
cho anh em phỏng vấn được Việt Nam nên
là thực ra nó sẽ kéo hướng là toàn bộ
tiếng biết nhé. Mấy ông thấy ổn không ạ?
H các question
remove
grap đi.
Ừ.
Ừ
con codex ngon quá mà em đăng ký plus
free áp thẻ vào
không thẻ nào nhận hả đăng ký free á
bởi vì theo IP cọ mọi Mình lạng rừng quá
nó nhả nhà nó bị thế
em phải anh không thể nói em phải mua
được nhưng mà nói riêng là chỗ nào
ừ
đầu tư nào nó cũng đáng đấy mọi người
thấy mình dùng cũng thoải mái đúng không
để phút vào thì cũng vất vả đấy nên là
Tôi đang đợi nó ngồi sửa lại cái
section này để tôi ngồi tôi ngồi làm
tiếp không ạ?
xóa diễn viên my solution các thứ thứ
trước khi sửa lại
xay nội dung các thứ thứ luôn này đấy
tắt này ra ngent
window zoom
Notification
à đâu
cần biết được mình đang cái cũng được
xóa sơ đi gọn lại
Ok. Cần
cái này cho một loạt từ tiếng Anh nhưng
mà không hề nhắc thấy ở trên này.
cũng được. Gọi là đây là không phải chú
thích thuật ngữ nữa. Đây là keyword luôn
cũng được.
Kiểu người học luôn tiếng Anh được.
Ủa không bị ghi đề khi nhiều quản lý
thao tác. Thì cái này như mình nói là
à
với
lư
lịch sử
đây rồi
nắm rõ
có quản lý của từng mạng địa điểm
cũng như quản lý
tổng,
quản lý địa điểm nếu cần thêm nhân sự.
sẽ yêu cầu
nhanh
cấp trên
để cấp trên vào
phê duyệt
tự đề xuất
ra các nhân viên đang
sống ở vị trí đó
thậm chí
có thể là nhân viên chống nhưng đã hóa
giới hạn số làm nghiệp thì cảnh báo
nhưng vẫn đề xuất
cái này có nhưng mà nói chung là này sẽ
tự mình thương lượng với nhân viên đấy
xong coi như là giờ làm thêm này ot đúng
không hoặc là thậm chí là [khịt mũi] gì
gì đó.
Ừ nhưng mà tôi chưa biết là có thể đồng
chỉnh sửa đồng thời là cũng làng ngangng
đấy.
Tạm thời trước mắt thầy đã. Mấy ông có
câu trả lời mà cho cái này thì cứ nhắn
nhá. Tôi sẽ ngồi.
Ok xong rồi sẽ có gửi lại bài làm của
mình.
Solution
đấy. Sing này đấy. Mình chấm điện đi
bạn.
Đấy.
Enter. Chấm cho tôi.
Hôm qua anh chấm bài của anh được 4/10
4/10. Tôi nghĩ là xong về
triệu.
H
Mấy ông thử đoán xem tôi vừa rồi trả lời
thế tôi được mấy điểm
tôi cần chưa xem
tôi trả lời tôi vân mẫu
tôi tự tin mà bây giờ tôi cũng phải hơn
hôm qua trên bốn Để
không chắc nó không chơi hệ phẩy đâu.
Chắc là năm đổ lên đ không nhỉ? Mình
trình bày xong cũng thế văn vở rồi. Thầy
cũng văn vở rồi. Thầy cũng có tư duy
rồi. Nếu mà đi phỏng vấn tôi tự chấm là
có tư duy rồi là chưa tới rồi.
[tiếng cười]
Đị
mẹ được ch
[tiếng cười]
thật không sao đâu phải khẳng định hơn
ông quá
qua cũng được
cười vãi
bà làm hiểu đúng thương lớn tám th người
và gặp bùa có audit
không quản lý nhêu cấp có kỹ năng hành
nghỉ đổi ca và công bằng làm tuy nhiên
bài viện đó là danh sách ý tưởng trở
thành thiết kế hệ có requirement data
model API data flow chơ
conf từ thật ra tí thôi phải sửa lại
không cần data mod với API lắm nên phải
tí xem nó cái phần dưới như nào sẽ em
đang nhìn đúng cho domain hơn là chỉ ưu
lịch đểm tốt và nhận lại ra phần lịch sử
thay đổi nhiều nhiều giữa nhân viên ý
nhân viên phù hợp và cảnh đáover nhưng
trong phòng đế sin cần một database
master chưa đủ để đảm bảo đ
anh đánh ra ạ anh đánh giá sao về dnet
core
không biết codnet
không biết đánh giá kiểu gì
anh nghĩ là em đánh giá anh quá cao
[tiếng cười]
nhưng mà đừng quan tâm về ngôn ngữ. Nếu
mà giả sử em đang định học ngôn ngữ nào
đó thì em cứ học thôi.
Em cứ thấy ngôn ngữ dễ để học càng tốt.
Ví dụ gần đây anh thấy thế mạnh nhất bây
giờ đang học pon này là đấy thần đúng
không? Học rồi có mà. Và cái quan trọng
quan trọng lớn nhất ấy đó là
dễ học ở đây không phải là ngôn ngữ đấy
dễ học đâu nhỉ mà là môi trường của em
có dễ học về ngôn ngữ đấy không ví dụ
nhá ví dụ một cái định hình nhất nhá để
hồi trước anh dạy PP là dĩ nhiên thằng
sinh viên anh có một thằng sinh viên chỉ
thích MC thôi hoặc là chỉ thích Java
thôi chẳng hạn là tự nhiên kiểu một mình
nó phải đi học cái đấy nghĩa là nghĩa là
kiểu cả lớp thì đang học ngệm khác này
xong rồi
Thầy giáo cũng không dạy cái ngôn nữ đấy
chẳng hạn về sau mới dận nhưng mà đang
nói gian đầu tự nhiên mình mình tự nhiên
làm khó mình mình phải chập vật mình
ngồi học một mình chẳng hỏi được ai vân
vân hồi đấy thì chỉ biết tra Google hỏi
ai chợ trợ giúp mọi thứ đâu đúng không
mình gặp vấn đề gặp bậc gì đó tự mình
phải ngồi tự mò tự tìm đấy ông hiểu ý
tôi không tức là ông muốn học hay ông
muốn làm một cái gì đó giống như kiểu ví
dụ giả sử một cái điền hình nhất ở ngành
nghề khác đi kiểu ông muốn đi làm một
cái nghề gì đó đôi khi là ông nhất quan
hệ đúng không nĩa là ông phải có người
chồng lưng ông phải có người quen ở
trong ngành nã để người đấy có thể hỗ
trợ được ông để mà ông đi nhanh mà ông
đi xa hơn có người đi cùng thì sẽ luôn
tự tin đi được xa và đi nhanh ạ đấy
chứ bây giờ tự nhiên là ông không có lợi
thế nào cả rồi chỉ vì thấy là ơ mọi
ngươi bảo cái này mọi người ở đây là còn
mọi người chưa mất chẳng chẳng quen biết
gì mình cả thì lúc mà ông có vấn đề ông
có đi hỏi lại cái người trên mạng ấy
được không ông hỏi tôi này tôi bảo tôi
nói thẳng tôi không biết vì sau ông
không thể nào mà kiểu nhắn tin cho tôi
là anh hồi trước bảo em học đọt nét bây
giờ anh giúp em đi em gặp khó ăn anh
giúp em đi chịu kiểu thế đúng không tất
cả
quan trọng là có môi trường để mà ông
học một cái gì đó. Đấy,
không nên theo số đông mà là theo cái
môi trường đấy có phù hợp cho ông học
một cái gì đó không, hỗ trợ ông học cái
gì không? Đặc biệt là trong ngành nguyện
thông tin này càng dễ nạn và
ông nào mà theo được thì mới xịn nhá.
Ông nào không theo được dễ nạn cực luôn,
không có người xung quanh không người
không cảm thấy mình lạc loài kể. Bợi ngợ
thì khó lắm đấy.
Nhưng mà hoàn toàn hai điểm là ông học
xong cái này ông vẫn thể nhảy sang học
cái khác ở trong ngành này khá là dễ.
Ngày khác là tôi không biết nào nhá.
Ngành khác là đối ông nhảy sang cái khác
một chân trời mới mẹ luôn t. Còn trong
ngành này là ông học một cái này ông
nhảy sang cái khác nó sẽ có rất nhiều
điểm tương đồng. Nó phải đến 50 đến 70%
điểm tương đồng. Đấy thì ông sang cái
khác nó vẫn dễ. Ông có học một cái rồi
ông có cái tư duy sẵn cái việc học công
nhện tin trong đầu ấy n ông sa thế khác
học vẫn trễ giống như tôi đang học một
cái mới này cái này đối với tôi mới nhá
tôi vẫn học nữa đấy chứ nếu mà ông tôi
nghĩ là công nghệ thông tin này nó sẽ có
hồi trước tôi nói hai ba giai đoạn khó
gì đấy ông mới học thì sẽ giai đoạn khó
đầu tiên đó là giai đoạn mà mình chả
biết cái gì cả hàng tỷ thứ xung quanh tỷ
thứ còn đọc thì k thì thứ còn hiểu đấy
rất nhiều thự ghế mới th ra và ưu tiên
ông mà vượt qua được cái đấy là ông sẽ
cảm thấy phải đến tầm hai ba năm gì mọi
thứ nó khá trơn chu mọi thứ đều đều đều
ổn ổn khi về sau giai đoạn thứ hai đó
giai đoạn mà ông chẳng biết ông cần phải
học thêm cái gì [khịt mũi]
nghĩa đến cái nữa mà ông biết làm rồi sẽ
đến cái giai đoạn mà ông sẽ phải học n
cao hơn gì gì đó tức giờ ông sẽ hơi bị
mất phương hướng không biết mình học cái
gì để mà bổ trợ cho công việc của mình.
Lúc đây cũng không giống như tôi dần nói
là không thể ông cứ lên mạng, ông cứ phỏ
vơ chứ không thể trả lời ông được. Đấy
nó phải theo cái hoàn cảnh phù hợp của
ông. Ví dụ bởi vì ví dụ là tôi tôi biết
rõ được là
tôi muốn hướng đến cái
ví dụ là tôi về sau tôi muốn hướng làm
stack, muốn làm desktop hay là thậm chí
là muốn làm product owner kiểu thế thì
sẽ cần học thêm gì. Nhiều người thì học
kiểu làm một thời gian thời gian c quên
mất là cần phải học thêm ấy. Biết những
người mà đi làm 5 năm rồi người ta người
ta vẫn chỉ biết mấy cơ bản thôi. Làm đi
làm lại một cái cơ bản thôi. Không nên
đúng không?
Họ họ
độ trình thăng tiến của họ họ vẫn không
lung lắm.
Ok. Hơi giản chải không th ạ?
Hôm nay không như hôm qua được không hai
tiếng được vì ạ
không mang pin. Thực ra tôi cũng chỉ cần
như thế không cố tình không mang pin. No
no
chúng ta chỉ cần
on trên kiểu ngồi học trong vòng hơn
tiếng thôi
chưa đủ để đảm bảo correct need lịch
đúng hay sai phụ thuộc vào viết conflict
trong transition
à nó muốn cố đề cập transition này trong
đây cũng được cách khóa version schedule
con dữ điểm và nào hot shop? Ừ đúng rồi.
Còn nhấn mạnh ru hot shop. Ô như cái này
tôi không biết là mấy ông có thấy mấy
cái này ngầu hay là chữ này không hay là
đôi khi là mấy ông cũng mặc định à.
Nhưng mà cái này do AI làm nên đừng cần
thành AI nữa chửi nó. M cái này tôi thấy
xị
điểm đúng nhận ra nguồn dữ liệu nhất
quán để tránh lịch bị xung đột này có đ
biết gia phát các thứ thứ lịch làm pay
pon này mấy ông biết là gì không cái này
liên quan đến việc là trả lương trần
công
có phân quyền quản lý địa điểm và quản
lý tổng luồng phê duyệt khi thiếu nhân
sự ok này Nhớ
có ý về đổi ca báo nghỉ đăng ký lịch
sạch bận từ đầu tuần có nghĩ về phết
bằng xi vòng
giới hạn giờ làm biết đặt câu hỏi từ
cách chu phối nhân viên giữa điểm sai
chưa tách rõ
requirement và non
và
quan trọng
Agency
ở dưới nó có
cái a gì nhỉ?
Nó vẫn thiếu mấy cái từ khóa nó phải có
cái ở dưới cái gì nhỉ?
Ừm.
phải chú thích ở bên dưới những cái từ
khóa
chil API hoặc chính tạo thì candidate
SH
tôi bảo tí tôi sẽ bảo là bỏ data model
tôi ghi luôn đây luôn đây đi
tôi sẽ vào sửa lại cái này tí
À tôi mới thử chấn thử
và cần sửa lại thứ nhất không quan tâm
tới API
model
thì đây là phản vấn
thiết kế hệ thống
thiên về database
là hệ thống chứ không phải chi tiết
về
kiến trúc backend.
Hai cách cốt
có nhiều thuật ngữ
tiếng Anh khi chấm
nên có
phú thích bên dưới
sa còn có thể dùng skill
để
trắc nghiệm
dựa trên các từ khóa này
sao
chư định vẽ conflict 2 kỹ năng trùng ca
nghỉ phép vượt giờ thiếu số lượng người
vi phạm thời gian nghỉ dễ
à có thời gian nghỉ rỡ cao mấy cái này à
cái này tôi không biết này
tôi nghĩ là không cần này lắm
không tự giải quyết to edit nếu hai quản
lý không cho vẫn có thể ghi đèn nếu mà
không có in mytic locking đúng rồi như
vừa nãy nói quên mất cái vụ locking với
chon
Robin chỉ giải quit F đơn giản không đủ
cho schedule nhiều con chest nên xem nó
là ranking
ui từ phá này luôn không biết chưa nói
rõ cont và sub contract
chúng ta time of ru thường là h
giờ có thể là họ arrive tùy policy đúng
rồi chưa có failing
phần fail
chưa nhắc đến đúng rồi đúng rồi quên mất
cái vụ cả thông báo cho nhân viên thứ
thứ mà [khịt mũi]
phản biện thiết kế đềm phần sở mạnh nhất
là chả đúng với phần đề xuất cho thầng
mụ
nhân viên được vào 2k overlap là lỗi dữ
liệu không ai báo
con quency cũng là điểm
không bị ghi đề mai có em chưa trả lời
liệu
thiếu
sất nhân viên nó có thể đề xuất nhiều
khóa rồi và tiếng báo cái này ổn nhớ s
nhưng phải có
một lý do
ý nâng cấp
em bắt đầu nhảy sang code rồi.
Tôi nghĩa là sẽ xóa cái
không cần phần
điện thiết kế.
Gì năng tất
đời giải mẫu
tròng bè có từ config Cầm
xem cái này dạng à review cho đẹp nhá.
Trong lag này review của tôi đâu?
Review đâu?
H
Em nghĩ nên tập trung vào khái niệm AI
đưa ra mà anh chưa hiểu.
Xong tập trung thêm về khái niệm nào.
Đâ xem thực ra bài học này em nghĩ là
nên tập trung vào khái niệm AI đưa ra mà
anh chưa hiểu. Tập trung thêm về khái
niệm đó thay vì xem AI chấm minh bao
điểm và chưa tí chỗ nào. Đúng như anh
bảo đây th chắc là em chưa nghe đến
nguận ở đấy. Đó là
là có những từ khóa như em vừa nói là
những cái khái niệm mà anh chưa biết
đúng không? Anh anh đang muốn là sẽ dùng
sẽ nó sẽ tổng hợp hết ở bên dưới xong
rồi xong rồi anh sẽ có một cái skill là
kiểu tạo ra bộ trách nhiệm dựa trên
những cái từ khóa, những cái keyword các
ngữ đấy các thứ để làm flash cá với
trắc nghiệm qu để mà kiểu sau đó về sau
mình ôn lại được. Hiểu không? Nghĩa là
ngoài việc là có đề mình làm đề chấm
xong rồi chấm đề như này nhá thì mình có
những cái bộ từ khóa thuật ngữ những cái
keyword trong của cả đề đấy và cả câu
trả lời của anh cũng như là câu trả lời
của ai đúng không? Sau đó thì mình về
xong mình dựa vào đấy để tạo ra một bộ
đề nữa. Bộ đề đấy chỉ xoay quanh đểu
mình ôn lại những cái phần ngữ đấy để
mình hiểu thôi. Đấy thì cha là nó đúng ý
em đang nói đúng không? Đấy
đúng nhỉ? Còn nếu không đúng thì ngồi
giải thích kỹ hơn.
Anh anh đang hiểu nó sẽ như thế.
Thế nên là anh cũng đang bỏ bớt mấy cái
liên quan đến AI chấm này. Mấy cái này
thực ra không cần, anh chỉ cần nó chấm
và kèm theo cái
điểm thiếu hoặc sai này là điểm đúng này
là được này. Nhận xét nhanh này. Thế là
đủ rồi. Thế là thực ra nó chỉ cần đến
đoạn này thôi. những cái đoạn dưới này
không cần đấy.
chưa
chưa bảo nó sửa lại đúng cái a
chấm lại đúng cái a
chắc phải bấm lại đây thôi.
Bấm lại cho tôi
để
hỏi lại câu này
xem thấy ổn đã rồi mới sửa
còn 26%.
Ok, chắc là được
10 5 phút nữa.
Hôm nay cũng không một tiếng rồi. Mỗi
ngày học
mỗi ngày học hơn tiếng 100 ngày điện
vấn.
Nhưng mà hôm nay tôi mới buổi thứ ba như
tôi thấy tự tin dần về cách thiết kế của
tôi rồi đúng không ạ?
Tôi biết mấy cái này mà làm trẻ không
nỗi làm
như một kiểu một thằng nhu như một thằng
chẳng biết gì các thứ này làm trẻ mình
cũng có động này nó chạy được vẫn khó
hiểu. Ví dụ vừa rồi nó đưa ra mấy cái
kia mình cũng ừ mình cũng biết được
bản chất nó như nào chẳng mình chưa nghĩ
đến chứ không phải là ui mấy toanh chưa
cần nghĩ đến đấy nó khác
ra
nó chấm lại thành bốn á
>> tại sao nó tm đi của mình nhở cay thật
sai chọ tầm tầm bổ sung
này phương
chập ngũ ô ok
duyệt đấy.
Sửa các file khác cho tôi
đấy ông ông ông thấy không? Nghĩa là nó
chấm ra như này đúng không? Mình sẽ để ý
kéo thử các thứ này
và nó cho mình những cái thuật ngữ này
đúng không? Xong rồi từ đấy tí tôi cũng
bảo nó ngồi làm thử một cái
một cái bài trắc nghiệm để mình ôn lại
mấy kiến thức này
được mà.
Mấy ông vào bình luận toàn hai ba câu
rồi mấy ông mất tích làm tôi đi
thôi
các bạn nh
kịp tương tác gì ạ.
Ơ có cloud MD à
trong thư mục này là gì có cloud MD này
nói chung mục này có agent mình
Đ nhỉ?
này.
Xem đây rõ nhất này. Xem tôi toàn xem
không biết mấy ông xem cái trên ở đâu.
Tôi thưởng anh xem pha đây rõ này. Đọc
đọc gì?
Ừ tôi còn chưa xem cái official solution
nữa. Tôi chưa bảo nó sửa lại cái vụ
official solution.
Cách hiểu đề không chỉ là danh sách
chúng ta làm
sự phù hợp cái arve
phản bình nhân sự. lịch công
conflict với hỗ trợ mem
audit
ừ nó vẫn bị một cái là data model trong
này
solution
đang lưu
lưu thừa
data model nà
ừ
ATI
à nên ghi lâu lại rất là hay đúng không?
conflict handling
off
cũng là người học ai viết thôi anh phải
tin vào kiến thức bản thân tự ngộ ra đi
anh
Có anh vẫn tự ngộ ra mà tự tin chứ.
À
hình như đấy nhá.
Nếu ông để tăng rồi để hiểu cái danh này
chứ chẳng phân biệt được ai với ai cả.
dùng trong
mình chết off
khi người ta gái hơn mình ấy chứ không
mục tiêu yêu mình học thì tốt hơn bản
thân mình mà anh không phải là thực ra
anh học không phải là để mỗi trả lời
phỏng vấn đâu là để thực sự làm được
việc đúng không thì tất cả mình sẽ cải
thiện được trên bản thân chứ đôi khi là
đôi khi là kiểu
đôi khi là kiểu cái cách mình nói mình
tự tin gọi là chật rõ đi đúng không khi
đừng nhận đôi khi không không biết được
có khi đi làm rồi người sẽ biết được
mình thực sự làm được việc hay không mà
đúng
Đấy,
architect.
Architect này tôi vẫn đang nghĩ là không
cần lắm.
Nó có flow này rồi. S mẹ
nhỉ.
Thôi vẫn cần mà liên quan về sau chiếc
phức tạp coi như kiểu
bên xử lý
conflict hay link.
Concurrency check off
cả phần câu trả lời về nữa
tạo skill
tạo file này cho tôi
lại rồi
việt
Tôi phải
skin
tôi như ý là có conflict ở đây.
Hỏi bạn
à nội dung quân cáo
và đề xuất
sự phù hợp
hơi lạm dụng a
không con qu tranh thủ làm xong cái này.
này thôi chắc cũng chắc cũng nhìn
sự trong plan và thậ hiện đang có bing
gì kỳ vọng gì sẽ trồng trách nghiệm ở
đâu sau đó hỏi bạn trước format ok
đấy có ông vừa nãy bảo là trông ngon nhỉ
đúng ông thấy ngon đúng không ông thấy
làm ít nhất là làm liên quan văn bạch
mọi thứ trong vẻ rất xị
Tôi dùng thằng cloud để mà sửa văn bản
đâu. Tôi thấy không ưng lắm.
Câu trả lời giữ cách hiểu một thiết kế
các thứ thứ bottom next. Ok
ba skin chị nhận tch dọ ba vai tạo ba
file chấm my
chấm
đúng rồi chưa
ô ok
hợp lý luôn
hồi đầu tôi dùng conex để tôi không quen
mấy không tự nhiên nó ghi đi h bị ra kia
xong ngồi hồi đầu tôi bằng tiếng Anh
xong rồi nó ra một đống câu hỏi bằng
tiếng Anh với một đống từ khóa chuyên
ngành trông kiểu choáng
từ hóa chuyên ngành ở đây còn không phải
đấy còn làm giao diện nữa thế là nó toàn
nó mới cái kiểu hàm của Java Squid kiểu
mình không hề biết hàm tồn tại xong nó
hỏi là kiểu bạn muốn tôi sử dụng hàm này
hàm này hay hàm Không
>> sợ tôi phát nó ngồi giải thích tôi vã
chưởng
này. Ok
tôi tự tin thôi. Nếu mà đời [hắng giọng]
máy sắp tin rồi. Nếu như anh em không
còn câu hỏi gì tôi xin phép tôi tạm mà
đóng livestream lại xong rồi tôi sẽ để
cái này lên git để cho anh em có thể đấy
anh em thể tự ch
trả lời cái các câu hỏi của các đền này
xong rồi bản chập nhau nhá
đấy với điều kiện anh em có ai nhá xin
chào anh
Đ